our season has been a seasons of firsts
you know snatch game lala perusa a top
five season 14 of rupaul's drag race is
one for the herstory bucks one of the
longest running drag race seasons season
14 has been the talk of the town with
all its twists turns and golden
chocolate bar moments
as we gear up for the grand finale we
want to look back at the top five most
shocking and gag-worthy moments of this
season to start off the list we have to
talk about the moment when there were
only tops of the week and no bottoms no
bottoms
ladies
you represent the tops of the week
[Music]
that's right you all did such an amazing
job this week there are no bottoms
imagine that in west hollywood
in episode seven the top two queens
diabetes and lady camden got to lip sync
for the win and earned the cash prize of
5 000
now considering lady camden's shocking
runway reveal that will go down as an
iconic drag race moment we're quite
happy she earned the win of this episode
since we talked about the tops it's now
time to talk about the bottoms and a
shocking moment from this season has got
to be when the golden chocolate bar
finally came into play after trying to
prove herself in the rusticle bosco
wound up in the bottom against lip sync
assassin george's
unfortunately bosco was eliminated
that is until the drag gods had spoken
and it was revealed that she had the
golden chocolate bar
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks to this moment bosco is now in
the finale and might just earn herself
the season 14 crown who said a little
chocolate isn't good for you
now we need to talk about carrie colby
and the iconic jlo versace dress during
the jennifer lopez inspired episode each
queen was asked to rock their favorite
j-lo look with carrie colby coming out
wearing the actual versace dress jlo
wore to the grammys in 2000 talk about
iconic however things took a turn when
carrie was in the bottom and had to
lip-sync for her life all while not
ruining this very expensive dress
i am definitely devastated i'm also
thinking how in the hell am i going to
lip-sync in this dress because if i mess
up this dress i will literally y'all
will lose me i won't be found i'll be
dead
luckily colby pulled through won the lip
sync and even got to perform with j.lo
herself at the iheartradio music awards
alongside her season 14 sister alyssa
hunter
now one of the most shocking moments of
the season has got to be the unexpected
withdrawal of cornbread
cornbread was certainly a front-runner
receiving major praises from stars such
as lizzo and ariana grande however after
mentioning her ankle was hurting in
episode four it was announced that
cornbread had twisted her ankle and
sadly would have to remove herself from
the competition in order to heal
although this came as a big surprise to
many fans et canada caught up with
cornbread who assured everyone she's got
big plans for the future including an
album in the works i definitely want to
introduce like a good seven phone story
line kind of moment
the biggest twist in a season filled
with gag worthy moments really has to be
the fact that we are entering the finale
with
five queens
we have a top five damn it
after the most recent episode with best
friends willow pill and angeria paris
van michels having to battle it out for
the final spot in the finale rupaul that
trickster revealed that they would both
be continuing on to the end
congratulations you will also be moving
forward
to the grand finale with this the season
14 winner will either be angeria
bosco
diabetes
lady camden
or willow pale
which queen are you rooting for to take
home the season 14 crown am i allowed to
have favorites i don't care i do
personally i'm rooting for there's two
willow pill or diabetes but honestly i
really would be happy with any of them
this season has been stacked with talent
and it really is sure to be one for the
herstory books
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos